[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]
AMIT SOOD: I hope I
can get your attention
at 6:30 PM this
evening for a talk
that I hope will inspire,
entertain, and just
be chaotic in general.
We are going to try and
do quite a few things.
We have a short amount of time.
But, essentially, we're
going to talk to you
about what Google is doing when
it comes to arts and culture.
And for those of
you who know what
Google Arts & Culture is, great.
For those of you who don't, I'm
going to keep it really short.
My name is Amit Sood.
I work in the London,
Paris offices of Google.
And I'm joined on stage here
with my colleague Damien Henry.
Damien is our head off our
experiments team based in Paris
and responsible for
a lot of the things
that I'm going to show you.
And so if you don't like
something or like something,
talk to Damien.
I'm going to escape really
fast after the session.
But being very brief, Google
Arts & Culture started in 2011.
And it's a non-profit
non-commercial division
within the company that
essentially focuses
on making arts and
all types of culture
more accessible
using technology.
So we've been working with
museums, foundations, archives,
and artists for
now over 10 years,
and essentially trying
to get more culture out
there for everyone to
enjoy in different ways.
And so today, I'm not going
to talk to you so much
about what we do at Google
Arts & Culture in the core.
I'm going to talk to you what we
do with experiments, because we
want to try and show
you a few cool ideas.
So before I do that, I think
we're going to try and show you
a short video that talks about
the main platform, which,
by the way, you
can all download--
it's just called
Google Arts & Culture--
that has now over 6 million
artifacts, artworks,
and over tens of thousands
of curated exhibitions
from museums around the world.
So it's a short video to tell
you what you can do with it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
[END PLAYBACK]
So that's our main job.
We're not going to
talk about it much.
We encourage you all
to enjoy the app,
and essentially have
all the world's museums
and cultural topics
easily accessible.
What we want to talk
to you about today
are a few of our recent
activities in the field of arts
and culture.
And this is going to go quite
fast, so try and stay up.
But if you can find structure,
don't worry about it.
It's just a bunch of
really important cool stuff
that we're going to show you.
So preserving cultural heritage.
I think we decided to put this
at the start of the session
given some of you might know
about the recent tragedies that
have unfolded when
it comes to monuments
and amazing, amazing
cultural landmarks.
I'm not going to
name them, but I
think we all are aware
of what's been going on.
And so we've been working with a
partner called CyArk based here
in San Francisco.
CyArk has been one of
the leaders in capturing
and preserving cultural
landmarks using
cutting-edge drone technology
and photogrammetry.
And this is, by the way, called
the Open Heritage Project.
There's a lot of content here.
More than enough for you
to spend a couple of weeks,
so I don't have time to
take you through all of it.
But the idea is to tell
stories about preservation.
Why preservation is important.
But to also make it easy
for developers and anyone
interested in the
raw data of what
it means to capture a cultural
landmark to experience it.
So we're going to try and show
you one story of the Mexico
City cathedral.
I don't know how
many of you know
about this amazing building.
But after the
earthquake in Mexico,
the Mexico government
invited CyArk, our partner,
to come and preserve this,
so that in case anything
ever happens, there is a
high-density point cloud
photogrammetric model that
can be used for preservation
and restoration.
So this is a great story.
You can enjoy it.
But what's exciting
is models like these.
And we have over 50
of them now have--
it's going to load in a second.
This is all live, by the way,
so we're taking a few risks.
But hopefully, it will
be coming on soon.
That's it.
So that, by the
way, is the altar
in the cathedral that
has been captured
using drones that have
essentially allowed you to get
very high-density information
on the entire structural nature
of this altarpiece.
And if you want to
really understand
your perspective and the
view that you're getting,
I'm just going to ask Damien
to tilt down so that you
can see where you actually are.
This is a possibility now with
the kind of digitization tools,
the kind of work
our partners are
doing that helps preserve
but also storytell
about these amazing landmarks.
We also have, for example,
one of my favorites,
which is the Thomas
Jefferson Memorial.
If Damien just goes
back to the homepage,
I'll be able to very
quickly, as you go down here,
you will see cities.
You will see the
temples of Bagan.
And you will also see
what I've been finding
fascinating is the
fly-through of the Jefferson
Memorial, which has been
now preserved, again,
thanks to CyArk.
So this is an example
of preservation.
We have a few others
on the platform
that you can experience.
Damien can just fly
through, and you
can start exploring this
monument like never before.
Here's the main
news why we wanted
to talk about this at
I/O, because CyArk has now
agreed to opensource all this
data for anybody to download.
And so, essentially, you just
have to go to the platform,
apply, and you can
get the raw data
and start manipulating
it, playing with it.
We're already seeing
examples of developers
around the world
who are actually
finding new insights thanks
to these type of initiatives.
So moving out of
preservation and moving
into another area, which is
basically talking about what
we do with institutions.
And we wanted to
take two examples
that we launched very recently,
just a couple of months ago.
And how many of you
know who Vermeer is?
OK.
Not bad.
Well, he was a great artist.
Take it for granted, he was.
And you can google it
later to verify it.
But he was also an artist
whose works were very limited--
only 36, I think-- and they're
spread all across the world.
So there isn't
one Vermeer museum
that you can go and experience
these amazing works.
And you have CERN.
I hope you all
know what CERN is.
Hands up if you don't
know what CERN is?
OK, everyone knows what CERN is.
Great.
So what do these two
places have in common?
Both of them deal
with the problem
of recreating an experience
in the physical world that's
just not possible.
So you can't go to
sun to experience
the Big Bang for now.
You can't go to
a Vermeer museum.
And so here comes in
augmented reality.
And we're going to show you
two experiments that we've
launched live that
hopefully will work,
because they're going
to do it live on stage.
And these are public, so
you can download it as well.
So the first one we're
going to try and show you.
So, by the way, this
is the platform,
the Google Arts &
Culture platform--
and I'm going to try
and go a little fast--
which has daily amazing stories
from Van Gogh's, and a lot
of other crazy stuff.
I don't know if you know
what the art selfie is.
Try it out.
Over 100 million selfies have
been taken using this feature.
But here's Meet Vermeer.
So in partnership with
some amazing museums led
by the Mauritshuis
in the Netherlands,
and involving some other
great institutions,
we brought all the
Vermeer pieces together
on one platform in
high resolution.
But then the challenge
was, that's great,
but what if you actually wanted
to give the impression that you
were walking through a
physical Vermeer museum?
So we tried to experiment--
and this is an experiment.
We launched the complete
works in augmented reality,
and I'm going to
try and demo it now.
And hopefully, it will
not be a disaster.
So let me try and
find my surface.
And we're just waiting
for the model to load.
So great.
So that's the Vermeer
museum, which can't actually
exist in the physical world.
And you can check out the model.
You can pinch on it.
And then you can
jump right into it.
And this is now a Vermeer
museum in your house
that you can walk up to the
"Girl with the Pearl Earring,"
one of the most
iconic paintings.
And you can get to
brushstroke-level details.
You can move around.
And as you walk
around, you can start
discovering different rooms.
You can start walking
through other galleries,
other sections, and
essentially be in a-- oh.
That was a bit too ambitious.
But essentially,
back to reality.
Now back to augmented reality.
And as you can
see, you can start
going to every single work
of his in high resolution,
and start walking in
front of the paintings.
So this is an idea how physical
galleries that can be created
can be done through
augmented reality.
I hope you enjoyed, and
you can play with it.
By the way, you
can spend a couple
of hours in that gallery.
The next example I'm
going to show you
is actually about a project
we launched a few months ago
called Once Upon a Try.
115 scientific institutions
bought on the same platform
telling stories
about inventions.
Amazing, great fun, but
no time to show it to you.
But I'm going to show you one
component of that initiative.
And this was about how do we
get people to enjoy, and also
learn about the Big Bang.
Something we all know, the
word, but we don't take the time
to actually delve into it.
And so this is app created with
CERN and published under CERN.
And you can download it on
any of your different stores.
I'm going to go back
to the beginning.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- You're about to
experience the Big Bang--
the moment a tiny speck
packed with energy
suddenly expanded, giving
birth to space and time.
To see the universe form,
stretch out your hand
palm-up in front of your camera.
Make a fist.
Open your hand.
Just a billionth of
a second has passed,
and it's blisteringly hot--
around 10 million
billion degrees.
The energy of the Big
Bang has transformed
into a thick soup of quarks,
electrons, neutrinos,
and photons.
Quarks and electrons--
[PLAYBACK ENDS]
AMIT SOOD: So I have to pause
because I don't have time
to show you the
whole experience,
but that's a 10-minute
augmented reality storytelling
by Tilda Swinton
that really gets
you to understand the Big Bang.
And of course, if you are keen
on continuing the selfie trend
and want to take something
called the star selfie to share
with your friends.
You can actually
start doing that.
And now, I am a star selfie.
So you get the idea with
what we're trying to do.
Educate, but also create
something playful and fun.
So I'm going to move
on now very quickly
to another section which
we may have to skip,
because I'm running out of time.
But, essentially, what do
NASA and MoMA have in common?
They both are amazing
abbreviations, I think.
But they're also
great institutions.
And what they have
in common is they
both have used machine learning
in a very interesting way
to essentially solve a problem.
And I think we don't have
time to show you both,
but maybe we'll show you the
NASA experiment very quickly.
So NASA has a public
API that they've
made public, which has
around 300,000 images or more
of all the photographs
of missions
and many other topics
that NASA has made public.
But one of the challenges is
how to make sense of it all.
How to make sense of such
a large visual archive.
And so we created this
storytelling project
that essentially
allows you to navigate
through every single
mission photograph
that NASA has ever released in a
storytelling way using clusters
that have been tagged
using machine learning.
And, essentially, these are
tags that allow you to navigate.
So rather than navigating
through the image,
you're navigating
through these clusters.
So there are hundreds of
thousands of these clusters.
I don't have time to
take you through them.
But let's just
search for the Moon.
And when you search
for the Moon,
obviously, there are going to
be a large amount of images.
But what we wanted to do was
create a simple way for you
to enjoy each image and
the accompanying story.
So this is a very
simple, lean back,
you just have to sit
down, and the story
will come on the right side
on what each image has--
what role it has played.
And of course, if
you want to just see
all the images in a
visually stunning way that
has been categorized, you
just click on the visual view,
and then you have a beautiful,
beautiful, essentially, view
of all these images.
You can also find some
very strange words
that you would wonder why
they are in the NASA API.
But one of the words that
we found was lettuce.
Lettuce.
For all the
vegetarians out there,
it's a very important thing.
I eat a lot of lettuce.
And we found lettuce.
And essentially, we were
wondering, why has lettuce
turned up in this archive?
And it's because it's about
astronauts trying to grow,
essentially, lettuce in space.
And so you learn more about the
archive through, essentially,
tags, and through, essentially,
understanding of these words.
So you can spend a year
enjoying this experiment.
So we're going to
move on very quickly
and go to the next section,
which is to talk about--
I've taken you through what
we do with institutions.
we can do with a large photo
archive using machine learning.
And now I want to
talk to you about what
we're doing with artists,
with certain collaborations
that we've done.
We have some that
we're launching today.
That's in the next section.
These are two examples
of things that
are going to be actually
coming to you very soon
and are in development,
but we want
to show you both the examples.
So the first one we're
going to show you
is with an amazing artist
called Wayne McGregor.
Wayne McGregor is
the current resident
at the Royal Ballet in London.
But he's also one of
the individuals who
was responsible for
designing Harry Potter's
movements in the movies,
and he has done a lot more.
So google Wayne McGregor.
And we worked with
Wayne McGregor
to really tell a story
using machine learning,
how machine learning can
inform his art, rather than
the other way around.
So let's watch this
very short video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[ATMOSPHERIC MUSIC]
- One of the things that's
run through all of my practice
has been a relationship
with technology.
- So, when we started
working with Wayne,
we were really interested
about movement prediction.
We found a research
paper which [INAUDIBLE]
and writing prediction.
And we think, what
if we use that
for predicting dance movement?
We use the archive from
Wayne to train the algorithm
so they can use these
data to generate movement.
- When I'm with my
dancers normally,
what I'm asking them to do
through their own creativity
is make iterative
versions of an idea
that I might have proposed.
What this tool does
for each little moment
is do 400,000
iterations of that.
Yes, so the canvas
is way, way bigger.
We had to gift the archive.
And it was a huge archive--
thousands of hours of video
to be analyzed.
What this tool allows
us to do is go,
OK, I'm starting
with this phrase.
I would like the machine
learning tool, the AI
to invent the next phrase,
but in the style of Jordan,
or in the style of Jess.
And then you can get
combinations of those.
And then it's learning all
the time and feeding back.
And so this iterative
version gives you
all of these new possibilities
you couldn't have imagined.
[END PLAYBACK]
AMIT SOOD: So I hope
you are seeing a trend
in this chaotic
presentation, which
is that I'm trying to show you a
lot of different cultural ideas
that can all benefit from
some of the technologies
that we all have been
talking about here at I/O,
and that was dance.
And I'm going to show you a
very short clip, because we've
got to screen the actual
movie a little later,
but this was a collaboration
with an artist called Jenna
Sutela, and the movie will be
screened by Kenric and Damien
later.
So this is just a teaser
of the behind the scenes.
And this is really
something very opposite
from the dance example.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[WARPED VOICES]
- "nimiia cétii" is an
audiovisual artwork based
on machine learning,
teaching the machine to speak
in tongues.
So my name is
Jenna Sutela, and I
work a lot with words,
sounds, and living materials,
exploring biological and
computational systems.
I'm working with
machine learning
to generate a certain type of
glosso poetry based on Martian
language by the French medium
Helene Smith in the late 1800s,
and the movement of
Bacillus subtilis,
or the nocto bacterium
that are also
known as a test species in
spaceflight experimentation.
Together, the bacteria as well
as these early Martian scripts,
together with the
computer shaman,
will create a new
language altogether.
And the end result will be--
[END PLAYBACK]
AMIT SOOD: So I'm
going to end over there
because I see you
all so entranced.
The movie screens
after this session.
So just remember the key
words, "a computer shaman."
That's what she said, not me.
So moving on very quickly now
to, what do we have new at I/O?
Well, we have an
exciting next section.
We're going to go a little fast
just so we get everything in.
But I want to invite on stage--
actually, no.
Before I invite
on stage, we need
to do one last demo that
Damien is going to do.
We have launched today
an application developed
with an artist called
Zach Lieberman and Molmol,
a Brooklyn-based
artist collective.
And they have been doing some
fascinating stuff on education,
but also, when it comes
to augmented reality.
So Zach came and did a residency
with us at the lab in Paris,
and essentially
developed this app.
And this app launched
this morning.
It's available on
the Play Store,
so please go download
it, play with it.
It's quite crazy,
and it's out there.
So what we're going
to do is perhaps
show the video very
quickly, and then
maybe try and demo the app live.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My name is Molmol.
I am a artist, an
educator, and a researcher.
And we have a studio together.
- And my name is Zach Lieberman.
I'm also an artist, an educator.
And we're interested
in using technology
that is code and electronics,
but to create artistic work.
We're doing a residency here at
the Google Arts + Culture Lab.
Our goal was to
create an app that
allows you to capture
elements in the world,
and then paint
with them in space.
- We create a lot of interactive
installation that requires--
[END PLAYBACK]
AMIT SOOD: So now let's
show you the actual app.
Damien is going to try
and demo it very quickly.
So this is called Weird Cuts.
He's essentially cutting
a bunch of weird things.
Not that you all are weird.
Well, I am.
Perfect timing.
And the idea is you
use these cuts--
well, you don't do that.
But we use these cuts to
create, essentially, art in AR.
And that's the I/O logo there
done by Damien in a record 20
seconds, so.
[APPLAUSE]
So download Weird Cats by
Zach Lieberman and Molmol.
It's a lot of fun, trust me.
Especially if you have kids,
it can be absolutely addictive.
So moving on very
quickly to my next guest
and the next experiment that
we want to launch today here
at Google I/O, is
I want to welcome
on stage the lovely Pinar,
who has flown in from Europe
to join us.
And we're going
to talk about what
we've been doing with Pinar.
Pinar.
[APPLAUSE]
PINAR DEMIRDAG: Thank you.
AMIT SOOD: So rather than
me introducing who Pinar is,
I'm going to let Pinar tell
you why she's at Google I/O,
and what does she do?
PINAR: Thank you.
So I'm Pinar.
I'm an artist.
And, together with my
work partner, Viola,
we have a studio together.
Our main mission as creators is
to contribute to the progress
of social justice.
And we do this by using the
power and charm of visuals.
Normally, usually, even though
we partner with technology
and fashion companies
to make their products
relevant for the
contemporary, this
is the first time we are
collaborating with machine
intelligence thanks
to the residency we
did with Google Arts + Culture.
AMIT SOOD: Yes.
So Pinar came to us in Paris--
to Damien, actually--
and she wanted
to understand what we are doing.
We showed her what we are doing.
And I don't know how many
of you know who Alex is.
Alex works in a team
here run by Blaise,
who's going to join me
on stage in a second.
And Alex is also the founder
of the DeepDream sequence.
So if you move to the
next slide very quickly,
maybe we can see--
these are your works.
PINAR DEMIRDAG: It's insane.
It's like, you cannot understand
what I felt at that very
moment.
A year and a half ago, when
we met Damien in Paris,
he showed us the
discoveries of Alex.
That you see on the top
floor, these patterns
are made by machine intelligence
by a complex but simple system
that can extract images
from the way machine
can do visualizations,
feature visualizations.
And the images that
you see on the bottom
is our 10-year body of work
as fashion pattern creators.
So--
AMIT SOOD: So it's way before
DeepDream ever came on,
Pinar was somehow already
ahead of the game.
And that's a reassuring,
that a human was already
in this sequence.
So shall we go-- show
the next slide, and shall
we show the different types
of things that you discovered.
PINAR DEMIRDAG:
So what we did is
that we met with Alex,
obviously, the genius.
And I'm not a coder.
I don't know how to code.
So Alex had to do
something very simple,
like a tool that has only few
parameters, that you basically
place an input as an image.
The input is in the small image
that you see in the corner.
And then, according to your
quote-unquote aesthetic
parameter, you can play
with the parameters
and control the output.
So our role here as artists
was to curate the ingredients,
and guide the machine
and iterations,
and stop and extract
images in the moment
we found them beautiful.
AMIT SOOD: And I think if
you see the next slide,
I hope it's the one that-- yes.
That's a fantastic
slide, because that
talks about the original image?
PINAR DEMIRDAG: Yes.
So let me tell you.
The images that you
have seen before--
like the big image that you saw
on the screen, the pattern--
is actually what you
see in the middle, what
says DeepDream, the images
that DeepDream created.
And what is on the very left
is the flower, the heart, which
is the original input image.
And what you see on the right is
the compositions that we made.
So the images that
you see in the middle
come back in the
original image--
sorry, in the final artwork.
You must understand that this
is an incredible moment for me
because, normally, it's quite
a lot of an effort for me
to create images that come
from different backgrounds.
And artificial
machine intelligence
was an amazing tool.
First of all, it just
never gets tired.
It runs all the time.
It doesn't complain.
It doesn't get sleepy like I do.
And then it's like, it creates
these nonlinear images.
Like, I'm a human.
You know how I make images?
I put something next
to another thing.
I think linear.
But this thing thinks recursive.
So it creates things that
I've never seen before,
and they're really beautiful.
AMIT SOOD: And
where do you think
this will go for you as an
artist, this collaboration?
Where do you think
this will move towards?
PINAR DEMIRDAG: Yes.
I see two options.
Well, first of all, if I'm
given like a golden ticket,
I want to cover space rockets
for them to go to Mars.
But pattern is something
really beautiful.
It's a very volatile
surface, in the sense
that all three-dimensional
objects carry a surface,
so you can cover anything--
a phone cover, fashion, this
and that.
But what we want to
start with-- actually,
can we go back to
the former one--
is with an exhibition.
Because what you have seen so
far is only beautiful prints.
But we cultivated
so much knowledge
about future visualization
through the process.
For instance, when you place
a Buckminster Fuller molecule
as an input-- you know,
the carbon molecule--
in one go, it created a
snakeskin, and in another go,
it created a turtle pattern.
Another example, when
we placed a Nautilus--
this spiral animal--
and then when we placed
a DNA double string,
it created the same output.
So so much can be said
about the hidden patterns
of our universe.
And then the second
wish is to make
technology sexy with fashion.
We recently, as a studio, we
started making our own clothes
that I am wearing right now.
And like about artificial
intelligence, machine learning,
I find it the natural next step
in the progress of humanity.
But I'm afraid not
everybody sees the beauty
that I see in it.
And, as you know, fashion has
this, wow, fashion, glamor,
this instant glamor effect.
And I think artificial
intelligence
can make use of it.
AMIT SOOD: Yeah.
I think it's a excellent
example where, not only have
you co-curated,
but you also think
about how to make it more
acceptable to the masses.
PINAR DEMIRDAG: You are right.
Also, it's a great
conversation opener.
Like, what are you wearing?
Oh, I'm wearing a collaboration
between artist and machine
intelligence.
And you?
Just black?
How interesting.
AMIT SOOD: [CHUCKLES] Yeah.
I think the way you
said it is perfect.
A definite conversation opener.
OK.
So now we don't have a lot
of time, unfortunately,
because we have a next section.
But we're going to tell you
very quickly what's launching.
So this is launching today,
this story, which is available.
But what you can also
see is the actual tool
that we are publicly making
available thanks to Alex.
This is essentially
DeepDream, you could say,
V2 based on the 2018 paper.
It's not the 2014 version.
And it's a little
less psychedelic.
It's a bit more practical.
And it has a lot of
variations that you can do.
So this tool is now launched.
It's available to anybody.
Go in, put in any
image you want,
and see what you can
collaborate with.
I think we have one image--
I don't know if we can
do it very quickly--
which Damien took of me eating
my lunch, which I'm not sure--
that's the only one I could
find that was copyright--
I'm the copyright owner,
so I'm allowed to use it.
It's me.
So essentially,
if you take that,
and if you try and
very quickly, live,
see what the tool outputs,
it might take a second, but--
so here.
That's my lunch and me converted
into something quite abstract,
quite interesting.
But then you can start playing
with it with the toggles.
So the tool is available
on g.co/artsexperiments.
Yes.
That's me and my gazpacho.
So titled "Me and My Gazpacho."
So thank you so much, Pinar,
for working with us on this.
And thank you so
much to Alex, who
can't be here, who was
an amazing collaborator
on this project with Pinar.
PINAR DEMIRDAG: Thank you.
AMIT SOOD: Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
So, now, I'm going to be really
quick to introduce someone who
requires a very
long introduction,
but I'm going to try
and make it very fast.
So I welcome on stage
Blaise, Blaise Aguera,
who has been kind of like
an inspiration for us
here at Google Arts
& Culture because he
has been doing this work
way before Google Arts
& Culture came along.
And I think I have
this cards that I
want to read out very quickly.
But, basically, Blaise
leads a team at Google
now focusing on
machine intelligence
for mobile devices, both on
the research front as well
as the new products.
And the group works extensively
in deep neural nets for machine
perception,
distributed learning,
and agents, as well
as collaborating
with cultural institutions
and academic institutions.
Until 2014, distinguished
engineer at Microsoft,
where you worked in
a variety of roles.
And your TED talk,
which is something
that any TED aspirant should
enjoy, around Sea Dragon
and Photosynth in 2007
and 2012, and of course,
Bing Maps in 2010.
And in 2008, you were awarded
MIT's prestigious TR35.
So we are very happy
to have you here.
We are going to now get you
to talk about some of the work
that you're doing.
Maybe you can start talking
a little bit about just
DeepDream, and what your team
is doing around this area.
BLAISE AGUERA: Sure.
Thank you so much for
having me up here, Amit.
So we've been collaborating
with Google Arts & Culture
via a sister program
called Artists and Machine
Intelligence for some years now.
And the origins of DeepDream,
you've already alluded to.
This was Alex Mordvintsev
originally doing experiments
to try to understand
the neuroscience
of artificial neural nets.
When we first began to use
deep nets to understand images,
they turned out to be much more
powerful than previous machine
learning techniques.
And he was trying
to visualize what
they were doing on the inside,
to run them in reverse.
And those visualizations
yielded these incredible
hallucinogenic--
AMIT SOOD: And that's not
all your team has been doing.
There's been a lot of other
cultural engagements already
influenced based on the research
that your team is actually
doing, right?
BLAISE AGUERA: That's right.
So that really began the process
of thinking about deep nets
as not only being able to
understand or analyze media,
but also synthesize media.
So where the Cultural
Institute had
been using these
kind of technologies
to do things like classify media
and allow you to search them,
the next step was to
try and understand
what happens when they
begin to synthesize media,
and what kind of
new partnerships
are possible with artists, as
Pinar was just demonstrating.
AMIT SOOD: Exactly.
And what has been like one
of your highlight projects
from these cultural engagements?
What has inspired you?
BLAISE AGUERA: So I
brought a couple of slides,
nothing so flashy as
what you've been showing.
But there were a couple of
really interesting moments,
I thought, at various points
in AMI's history so far.
One of them was this
rather inglorious-looking
little bubble camera, which
Ross Goodwin, one of our artist
collaborators, drove
with Kenric McDowell
around in this car that had
this camera mounted on it.
And the camera was hooked up to
both an analysis and synthesis
neural networks.
Analysis in order to understand
what images were being seen.
Synthesis in order
to generate poetry
from the images that
were being seen.
So the inputs are
coming from the image,
and from GPS, and
from Foursquare API.
And this journey, this road
trip that references on the road
went through
industrial corridors
in the US that are
suffering a certain degree
of economic depression
at the moment.
"Red and white
flags and the stars
were like a curtain of
paper, like a broad stream
of flowers."
These kinds of lines come out.
Or in Biloxi, Hard
Rock Hotel & Casino
Biloxi, "a hotel in
Biloxi, a high fisherman
with a starry face, and a
stub of a coat on his face,
and his shirt looking
boldly across his mouth."
These sort of things
emerge from this network
that has been trained on a large
corpus of 20th century poetry.
And a little bit like
Pinar's experience,
you start to get
a spooky feeling
when you experience this.
There's something going
on in the interaction
between the corpora
of human art that
has been made in the 20th
century, the environments
that we've created
in the 20th and 21st,
and the neural nets that we're
now able to partner with.
AMIT SOOD: But can I
ask you a question?
Because now we've
shown a few examples
where people are co-creating
with an intelligent system.
What does it actually mean
for you, both on an abstract,
but also on a practical level?
BLAISE AGUERA: Well, I
don't think that we really
know yet where this all goes.
And that's one of
the reasons that we
thought it was so important
to begin these dialogues, not
only with artists, but
also with philosophers,
and critical theorists, and
all kinds of other disciplines,
all sorts of other people.
On the one hand,
art and technology
have always been
very deeply enmeshed.
And if we have this
idea about art,
of it being somehow very pure
and devoid of technology,
this is absolutely wrong.
No matter whether you're looking
at aboriginal technologies that
use dyes extracted from nature,
or you're looking at Henri
Cartier-Bresson
and photography--
AMIT SOOD: The printing press.
BLAISE AGUERA: --or
the printing press,
right, it's always been
a technological exercise.
And often, when the
new technology comes--
and photography is a
really good example--
there's a little bit of a
moral panic of like, oh my god,
what does this mean?
But of course, in
the end, we're not
really separate from technology.
I feel like we're all part
of the same sociotechnical
universe.
AMIT SOOD: So this engagement
is critical, right?
Like your group, apart from
this initiative on arts,
your group is doing a lot of
other very big impactful things
across Google.
And I'm just curious, what--
you are very busy.
You have a lot of
stuff going on.
But you still make
time out to focus
on this kind of
collaboration with artists,
thinkers, et cetera.
And I want to know, what is
the benefit to tech companies?
Why should tech
companies collaborate
with this type of entities?
BLAISE AGUERA: Well, we find
this engagement absolutely
critical to all of our work.
This isn't a sideshow,
or a 20% project for us.
I feel like there's an
insularity to Silicon Valley
culture.
And we've seen some
of the downsides
of that play out in recent
years along every dimension.
It's geographic.
Companies that are
based in Silicon Valley
often don't understand what the
impacts and the consequences
of technology are in
other places in the world.
They don't have their
eyes open through the lens
of other disciplines, and
other kinds of life ways,
and other ways of
interacting with people
and with technology.
So for us, I just came back--
Kenric and I were at the Strelka
Institute in Moscow for a week
last week in discussion
with Benjamin Bratton, who
is one of our artists
and machine intelligence
collaborators, and an
urbanist, an urban theorist.
And it was an extremely--
this was an engagement
that we're bringing back
into the lab and into our
work in a variety of very
concrete ways.
AMIT SOOD: So you are
finding practical nuggets
that you can actually take
from these engagements
and put it into the actual
larger technical world
that you're doing.
BLAISE AGUERA: Absolutely.
AMIT SOOD: OK.
And so obviously,
that means you want
more of these interactions.
BLAISE AGUERA: Yes.
AMIT SOOD: You don't
want less of them, right?
Because you want your main
work to be further enhanced.
BLAISE AGUERA: We
want to keep going
and to keep engaging, yes.
AMIT SOOD: So to
do that, I heard
that you and I and our teams
are going to announce something
today.
So why don't you--
BLAISE AGUERA: How
did you know, Amit?
AMIT SOOD: Well, because
we've been working on it.
But here it is.
You're going to
talk about thing.
Damien?
Please go ahead.
Go ahead, please.
BLAISE AGUERA: Yes.
So this was another project
that I didn't have a chance.
But I feel like we've already
shown maybe too many of these,
so perhaps we should
skip straight to the--
AMIT SOOD: I think we have
time if you want to do
another example or two, yeah.
BLAISE AGUERA: Do
we have a moment?
Well, this was a really
beautiful project.
So this is Ross
Goodwin's "The Road."
This is Rafik Anadol's
"Archive Dreaming," which
we were pretty excited by.
He first did this
experiment in 2017
with the SALT
Archive in Istanbul.
So this is an example of
another very large art
archive similar to the ones
that Damien was showing earlier.
And he created an
environment that
consisted of curved
screens and mirrors,
and let you explore the archive
in a very rich interactive way.
But also, Mike Tyka on
our team worked with him
with synthetic networks similar
to what Pinar was showing.
And so you could
both visualize--
[END PLAYBACK]
--the archive in a
variety of new ways,
and also synthesize media
that look like they belong
in the archive but didn't.
AMIT SOOD: Yeah, and
visually very appealing.
BLAISE AGUERA: And
visually quite intense.
AMIT SOOD: And now
I think we should
go to the grants program,
because in 28 seconds,
the doors will open.
BLAISE AGUERA: So in 24
seconds, the doors open,
so let's go straight
to the grants program.
AMIT SOOD: So this
is something new
that we are announcing
this year at I/O 2019,
and Blaise is going
to introduce it.
BLAISE AGUERA: So we're doing
six grants over the coming
year to artists.
It's over five months.
There's no commission.
There's not a requirement for
any specific artistic output.
But creative technologists
from Google--
Damien, and Kenric, and
engineering help from Google--
will work with those
artists and their practices
to extend their thinking
with these new approaches
and new technologies.
AMIT SOOD: Yes.
And this is a
formalization of the work
that Blaise's team has
been doing for many years
with the AMI project.
And we are starting small,
and starting humbly.
But we are hoping that these
grants will enable artists
to come and work with people
like yourself and Kenric
to essentially provide that
extra nugget for the work
that you're already
doing, right?
BLAISE AGUERA: Yeah.
We've had wonderful engagements
for this kind of thing
in past years, and now we're
formalizing it and scaling it
up.
So a wonderful partnership.
AMIT SOOD: Perfect.
So three new things
at I/O. Weird Cuts.
DeepDream V2, call it
Infinite Patterns launched,
and machine learning grants.
So don't tell it was not enough.
I hope that's enough.
And plus all the
other stuff we threw.
So thank you so much,
Blaise, for coming on.
Thank you, Pinar.
Thank you, Damien.
And we are right on time,
so you guys can go and enjoy
your evening.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]